يريد الاحتلال بكل ذلك ان يجعل من غزه
مكانا غير صالح للعيش ليسهل عليه مخطط
التهجير والنزوح عن ارضه ولكن نقول له
وداعميه واخر زائريه وزير حرب امريكا
خسئتم فلن تبلغوا مرادكم واذا كان وزير
حرب العدو في مؤتمره الصحفي قبل قليل يطلب
النصيحه من واقع خبره وزير حرب الاداره
الامريكيه فنحن نتساءل ما هي الخبره التي
يملكها هذا الامريكي هي هي خبره انتصار
كما في فيتنام مثلا او خبره انتصار كما في
افغانستان بعد 20 عام مثلا من القتال
يفرون يجرون اذيال الخيبه ان الخبره
الوحيده التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده
لهذا الجيش النازي هي قتل النساء والاطفال
وتدمير مير البيوت والمستشفيات والمدارس
ان شعبنا سيبقى في ارضه لانه ببساطه صاحب
الارض وصاحب الحق ووهم التهجير مستمد من
ثقافه هذا المجتمع اللقيط الذي بنته دوله
الاحتلال جالبه الغزاه من كل بلد لتسكن في
ارض لا ينتمون اليها ولكنهم يحتلون
وكلما ساءت ظروف حياتهم يلجؤون الى الهجره
العكسيه يعودون الى بلدانهم الاصليه كما
فعل مئات مئات الالاف من الصهاينه منذ بدا
طوفان الاقصى وان اسقاط التجربه على شعبنا
الفلسطيني هو قياس غبي غير مستبعد على
عقليه المحتل المختل لم يراعي اهم فارق
بيننا وبينهم اننا اهل الارض منذ الاف
السنين لكنهم هم الطارئ الذاهبون العائدون
الى مزابل التاريخ نحن نراقب هجرتهم
العكسيه من ايلات الى العقبه وعبر مطارها
الى كل مطارات العالم التين التي يحملون
جنسياتها لا